But what can we do for an equation like this? Notice that these two bases are
different. We have 16 raised to the x power. And 4 raised to the 3rd power. The
16 and the 4 are different bases. So, for an equation like this, we want to try
and get the bases to match. We want them to be equal. So, we can rewrite 16
with a base of 4. We'll have 4 squared which is 16 raised to the x. And the
right hand side will stay the same. We know by the properties of exponents when
we raise a power to a power, we multiply these powers together. This means
we'll have four raised to the 2 x, equal to 4 cubed. Now, since both of the
bases are equal, we can set 2x equal to 3. These exponents must be equal to one
another. And finally, we divide both sides by 2 to get one x is equal to three
halves. Now, this value for x should make sense in our original equation. We'll
have 16 raised to the three halves here. And we'll have 4 cubed on the right
hand side of our equation. We know that a fractional exponent really represents
a root. So, this really says that we have the square root of 16 raised to the
3rd power. We know the square root of 16 equals 4. So we'll have four cubed
equal to 4 cubed, so yes, this checks. You try solving this equation. Try
rewriting these bases so that way they're the same, and then see if you can
solve for x.